Caption: to be focused on today
Caption: and the one I'm personally most
Caption: passionate about is the system design
Caption: interview
Caption: so when we say certain design
Caption: a lot of people think we mean
Caption: architecture we're going to put up a
Caption: nice flow chart with you know database
Caption: here load balance here
Caption: and that's enough
Caption: there's actually a lot that goes into
Caption: certain design
Caption: and we're today we're going to walk
Caption: through a lot of these key Concepts
Caption: alongside that
Caption: we're also gonna go through the sponsors
Caption: which make a great conference like this
Caption: possible
Caption: so
Caption: thank you very much for the uh sponsor
Caption: today who helped make all of this
Caption: possible
Caption: bit of a disclaimer I haven't worked at
Caption: Google myself
Caption: what I'm going to be going through today
Caption: is based off my time and my experience
Caption: going through a lot of these concepts
Caption: with Google tech leads
Caption: and my own experience as an interviewer
Caption: this is the first time I've done a DDD
Caption: talk so I'm sure there's going to be
Caption: mistakes please bear with me
Caption: so
Caption: today
Caption: there's going to be kind of three parts
Caption: of this story
Caption: the first thing
Caption: we're going to go through is what a
Caption: interviewer is like
Caption: I assume well I assume some of you would
Caption: have done at least one interview
Caption: it's going to be going through kind of a
Caption: common pitfalls people make in system
Caption: design to views
Caption: we're then going to kind of distill that
Caption: down to I think the key point of the
Caption: talk which is the
Caption: the big reason people kind of fall down
Caption: not just at these interviews but
Caption: actually day to day when you're
Caption: designing your own systems
Caption: from there we're going to move into a
Caption: walk through
Caption: of how to really approach system design
Caption: in a structured way
Caption: I want to stress this isn't just going
Caption: to help you with interviews it really is
Caption: going to help you in your day-to-day
Caption: certain design
Caption: and I think if you're really paying
Caption: attention it's going to help mold how
Caption: you approach problem solving as well
Caption: so for our interview today we've got our
Caption: main characters we've got our
Caption: interviewer our system design
Caption: interviewer from tech company X
Caption: and us
Caption: the hopeful interviewee
Caption: so it's interview day
Caption: you're a bit nervous you're going to
Caption: skip breakfast
Caption: you're going to crack open your laptop
Caption: early in the morning and you're going to
Caption: check when your interview is
Caption: it's in about 15 minutes
Caption: you're going to want to join early don't
Caption: want to be late kind of make sure you
Caption: don't have any issues joining me tour
Caption: Zoom or whatever
Caption: the interviewer signs on right on time
Caption: and introduces herself
Caption: she asks you to introduce yourself as
Caption: well
Caption: and you kind of chit chat back and forth
Caption: a little bit
Caption: eventually she asks are you ready for
Caption: the actual interview
Caption: you say yes
Caption: she's then going to give you a prompt
Caption: what's the problem we're trying to solve
Caption: I want you to design a social media
Caption: application
Caption: where users can share messages with
Caption: their friends
Caption: so
Caption: think something like Twitter
Caption: luckily you're prepared for all this
Caption: you've done systems designing your
Caption: day-to-day you've done architecture
Caption: so
Caption: you end up with something like this
Caption: it's pretty standard looking I assume
Caption: most of you will have seen something
Caption: similar to this
Caption: nothing wrong with this kind of Stack
Caption: you know you've got a high availability
Caption: setup here you've got a database
Caption: and you start a gas tester behind a CDN
Caption: lots of best practice here
Caption: no big issues I think
Caption: can we handle more traffic
Caption: absolutely
Caption: sprinkle bit of cashing onto it
Caption: sprinkle casing everywhere
Caption: for those of you who haven't used red as
Caption: before it's an in-memory database that's
Caption: usually used as a cache so that sounds
Caption: good more performance
Caption: and I have seen all of these
Caption: configurations in my time as an
Caption: interviewer
Caption: we're going to add redis to absolutely
Caption: everything
Caption: and I'm going to talk a lot about
Caption: trade-offs today
Caption: but good thing is
Caption: everything's cached everything is going
Caption: to be way faster
Caption: one of the trails we make for this
Caption: performance is this is impossible
Caption: you can't do this
Caption: the only way you can connect redis up
Caption: here is to the service where it says
Caption: compute
Caption: sadly that's the least common way I've
Caption: seen reddest attached
Caption: so
Caption: your interview is going to call this out
Caption: that's really interesting but I don't
Caption: think that's quite possible
Caption: what other options do we have what else
Caption: do we see quite commonly when we're
Caption: doing these interviews
Caption: we'll throw kubernetes at it I'm not
Caption: entirely sure how that helps in any way
Caption: we're also going to go with cockroach at
Caption: it because it's new and because their
Caption: marketing team have done a fantastic job
Caption: it's like postgres but better in every
Caption: way
Caption: And I stress today we're really going to
Caption: talk a lot about
Caption: different approaches what the trade-offs
Caption: are and far far less about the
Caption: technology
Caption: one really common Pitfall is just
Caption: reading the front page of these
Caption: Technologies Dynamo is another one that
Caption: comes up you gigabyte Kafka whatever
Caption: they're going to pitch to you all these
Caption: great benefits
Caption: and they're going to say it's so
Caption: flexible it's useful in all of these
Caption: cases
Caption: you're really gonna have to dig for some
Caption: of those trade-offs
Caption: if you don't understand this well if you
Caption: don't understand what you're trying to
Caption: solve
Caption: you're going to end up in a bit of hot
Caption: water
Caption: you're going to end up with a
Caption: delayed
Caption: or incomplete solution
Caption: we haven't really gone through the
Caption: requirements so who knows what we're
Caption: really building
Caption: if we've if we're going to have a
Caption: lot of back and forth of product
Caption: after we've already already done a lot
Caption: of upfront design there's going to be
Caption: delays it's going to be oh but I thought
Caption: we were going to build it this way not
Caption: that way
Caption: if you don't talk to product at all
Caption: they're going to think you're building
Caption: one thing and you're going to have built
Caption: another thing
Caption: Your solution is going to be incomplete
Caption: it's also going to be expensive
Caption: you haven't really done much to look at
Caption: where your data is going look at what
Caption: compute you're going to need so you're
Caption: going to end up throwing a lot of
Caption: hardware at it which is going to come at
Caption: a lot of cost
Caption: it's also going to be unreliable
Caption: we've put up design up there
Caption: but
Caption: how much throughput are we actually
Caption: trying to handle how much load
Caption: do we need does our system need to be
Caption: able to support
Caption: and of course it's going to be buggy as
Caption: well
Caption: especially if you're going to go with
Caption: those hot new databases with a lot of
Caption: eventual consistency well we're going to
Caption: go through that later
Caption: so your interview is very nice very
Caption: professional very polite she's gonna
Caption: let you down gently and just say I don't
Caption: have any more questions
Caption: why should she
Caption: we haven't really demonstrated our
Caption: ability to explain our decisions so
Caption: she's going to save everyone time
Caption: as I mentioned at the start
Caption: we've made a few different mistakes here
Caption: but I'm going to take a shot at
Caption: distilling it down into one
Caption: really
Caption: what I think is a common cause
Caption: and giving it away a bit early but I
Caption: really think the mistake is
Caption: unintentional design
Caption: what I mean by that is we can get very
Caption: caught up in applying best practice
Caption: the best the newest technology the one
Caption: with the most performed at purported
Caption: benefits
Caption: the problem with that is when we're
Caption: asked to explain these decisions why do
Caption: we pick this and not something else
Caption: we might not be able to explain that
Caption: and that's kind of what I mean by
Caption: unintentional if it was an intentional
Caption: design
Caption: we'd much better be able to say yes this
Caption: is why we chose it
Caption: what we've actually done is really
Caption: sidestepped thinking about the problem
Caption: and just gone for a lot of shortcut
Caption: heuristics right which
Caption: I think best practices can be sometimes
Caption: so let's try this whole process again
Caption: but this time we'll do it with a bit
Caption: more intention
Caption: so let's wind back the clock
Caption: we or what is system design and I just
Caption: copied this straight from Wikipedia
Caption: it's defined at the architecture well
Caption: we've got a diagram so I guess we have
Caption: an architecture
Caption: we have product design
Caption: actually no we don't have product design
Caption: modules interfaces data we ain't got
Caption: that we haven't really talked about it
Caption: we don't have requirements to start with
Caption: now the product design part is easy
Caption: we're just going to blame product we'll
Caption: just Stonewall them off
Caption: divular solution and then fall over
Caption: what we actually want to do is really
Caption: collaborate with our with product or
Caption: your interviewer or just your team in
Caption: general
Caption: I think
Caption: this works both ways
Caption: product May some may simply throw
Caption: requirements over the wall and not
Caption: really want questions so you can do this
Caption: one in Reverse as well you deliver a
Caption: solution and blame engineering
Caption: if your company is particularly low on
Caption: funds you can blame each other much as
Caption: you want while you're packing all your
Caption: things into your boxes because
Caption: um we fail to Launch
Caption: so
Caption: on to the walkthrough
Caption: how we're going to get ourselves out of
Caption: this mess where we've thrown together a
Caption: really unintentional design
Caption: the first place to start
Caption: is function requirements
Caption: what are we actually trying to build
Caption: when we have a discussion with products
Caption: what are we going to talk about
Caption: uh we want to have a common
Caption: understanding of what we're trying to
Caption: build
Caption: so
Caption: winding back the clock
Caption: we want to talk about sorry we want to
Caption: design a social media application where
Caption: users can share messages with their
Caption: friends
Caption: so
Caption: what's the what are the key features
Caption: what things do we need to provide so
Caption: that customers can do that
Caption: the first thing
Caption: users do need to be able to post
Caption: messages
Caption: that's an important one
Caption: we also want to make sure that people
Caption: can share these messages with their
Caption: friends
Caption: how they're going to do that is by
Caption: following each other
Caption: and we also want to make sure that
Caption: you've got a nice feed of what all your
Caption: friends are saying
Caption: I think we can focus on these three
Caption: what I want to stress is that you don't
Caption: have to design every part of your
Caption: application here
Caption: you want to spend most of your time most
Caption: of your effort looking at areas or
Caption: features where either your product has a
Caption: lot of risk around it a lot of risk
Caption: around that feature
Caption: or where you're really going to extract
Caption: a lot of competitive advantage
Caption: and I think if we get these things right
Caption: at the very least we do actually have a
Caption: social media platform
Caption: so what about those things we left by
Caption: the side let's say authentication for
Caption: example
Caption: we can talk through that so for
Caption: authentication there's a lot of nice
Caption: patterns for doing this I want to say
Caption: it's a largely solved problem
Caption: I'm going to tell my interview with that
Caption: they're going to be okay with it and
Caption: we're going to move on
Caption: if they're not okay with it of course
Caption: you can have a bit of a chat about it
Caption: so we've made some progress here
Caption: just by refining the function
Caption: requirements we at least know what we're
Caption: going to build what our product is going
Caption: to look like
Caption: it's
Caption: there's less risk of your solution being
Caption: delayed
Caption: or
Caption: incomplete
Caption: you still have all these other problems
Caption: though how are we going to deliver these
Caption: users cases to our to our users
Caption: so we're going to move on to
Caption: non-functional requirements the things
Caption: that aren't features well we really need
Caption: to think through
Caption: and I think this is where it gets really
Caption: interesting
Caption: actually I will expand a bit more on
Caption: that
Caption: to be clear these are going to be things
Caption: that our application needs to support
Caption: it just isn't a feature users aren't
Caption: going to be too aware of it and you're
Caption: not going to put it up on your website
Caption: so
Caption: throughput
Caption: how much traffic does your site need to
Caption: handle
Caption: there's two major ways this gets split
Caption: up read throughput so reading against
Caption: your data stores reading against your
Caption: services it's usually pretty easy to
Caption: scale and scale horizontally too
Caption: write the report is a lot tougher and
Caption: comes a lot of trade-offs
Caption: which we're going to discuss later
Caption: so do we need to go away for a few weeks
Caption: and talk to our data team and really get
Caption: an exact picture of how much traffic we
Caption: are handling how many users we have or
Caption: we haven't launched it how many users
Caption: we're going to have
Caption: not really we can be pretty rough about
Caption: it we just want to get a rough picture
Caption: of is it a lot of throughput is it a
Caption: little bit of throughput
Caption: so we're gonna start with some napkin
Caption: math
Caption: a pretty standard prompt for this we can
Caption: just ask hey how many users are we
Caption: expecting to have
Caption: we're going to get back a number and
Caption: this is something collaborate product or
Caption: if it's an interviewer they'll likely
Caption: just hand it over to you let's just say
Caption: we have 100 million users
Caption: from that we can start to build a
Caption: picture we also need to know what
Caption: they're going to do in a day right we
Caption: want to know what is going to be hitting
Caption: our services
Caption: so
Caption: we can kind of go with our gut fear here
Caption: we're going to say oh an average user is
Caption: going to post up five messages a day uh
Caption: they're going to follow one of their
Caption: friends
Caption: and I'm going to Doom scroll a little
Caption: bit I have 20 views per user per day
Caption: sure
Caption: so we can start against some rough maths
Caption: if we have 100 million Daily Apple users
Caption: and we have five messages a day that's
Caption: 500 million messages a day or about 6
Caption: 000 requests a second
Caption: if our users are following one other
Caption: user a day 100 million follows a day
Caption: 1200 requests a second
Caption: those are both right ones
Caption: those are both right throughputs that's
Caption: how many write requests we're going to
Caption: need to handle
Caption: look it's kind of around the mid-range
Caption: the last one is reads
Caption: we're gonna have to do 2 billion
Caption: reads a day
Caption: 20
Caption: feed 20 users requesting their feed
Caption: every day
Caption: per user per day
Caption: it's a 24 000 requests read requests a
Caption: second
Caption: it's getting up there
Caption: we'll make a note of that I'll come back
Caption: to that later that's going to help guide
Caption: our design
Caption: we also need to take stock of
Caption: availability
Caption: so availability is our system's ability
Caption: to fulfill a functional requirement
Caption: it needs to succeed within a certain
Caption: span of time
Caption: why is that important
Caption: if users on our app try to send a
Caption: message and they keep getting errors or
Caption: it takes 30 seconds every time you post
Caption: a message to get a confirmation it's
Caption: going to be a pretty crummy experience
Caption: again
Caption: and I'm gonna Hammer this in so much
Caption: it's in collaboration with your product
Caption: team
Caption: well with with your wider team really
Caption: we're going to say
Caption: our users
Caption: most of the time
Caption: get a response within half a second when
Caption: they try to send a message
Caption: it feels about right again we can kind
Caption: of use our gut as long as we're sending
Caption: these products at these expectations
Caption: with product
Caption: we can follow another when we go to
Caption: click follow on another user it succeeds
Caption: most of the time within about two
Caption: seconds
Caption: it's done less often and users will kind
Caption: of just accept it that's what we think
Caption: anyway we don't have to get it perfectly
Caption: right we can always refine these things
Caption: tune our solution after we launch as
Caption: long as we've set our expectations with
Caption: product
Caption: the last one is really important for our
Caption: we want to encourage
Caption: why it's engagement right we really want
Caption: users to get stuck in that Loop of just
Caption: scrolling and reviewing a lot of their
Caption: friends posts so that really needs to be
Caption: really quite reliable and happen pretty
Caption: quickly you don't want them waiting or
Caption: if they get an error screen
Caption: they could very well leave right
Caption: we'll make a note of that and come back
Caption: to that later
Caption: consistency is a really interesting one
Caption: as well
Caption: consistency deals with guarantees
Caption: so
Caption: what what are the characteristics of our
Caption: system when we write data and read data
Caption: back from it
Caption: it's a whole huge topic all by itself
Caption: that I'm not going to go into
Caption: but
Caption: we can think we're going to use two
Caption: major models to categorize it for today
Caption: we have strong consistency where all of
Caption: your accesses are seen in sequence
Caption: that maybe sounds a bit bubbly
Caption: the important thing is this also means
Caption: when we write data to our stores or
Caption: write down to our services as soon as we
Caption: try to read it we're going to get the
Caption: latest date back it's strongly
Caption: consistent
Caption: on the other end of the scale and I
Caption: promise we'll get something for this is
Caption: eventual consistency
Caption: so
Caption: with eventually consistent systems
Caption: you're going to have all these updates
Caption: coming in
Caption: but when you go to read at any time they
Caption: might have said yeah we've accepted this
Caption: right we've accepted this new data
Caption: but you might not get the latest data
Caption: the only guarantee this gives you is
Caption: that
Caption: if rights stop coming in we'll
Caption: eventually get the latest date
Caption: let's take an ordering out for example
Caption: Amazon or something
Caption: when we go and order a new book
Caption: with a strongly consistent system when
Caption: we got our order history we're going to
Caption: see oh the new book we've ordered
Caption: cool easy
Caption: if we have an eventually consistent
Caption: backend what we might see is we purchase
Caption: a book we go to the order history
Caption: and there's nothing there
Caption: that sounds really bad in that case how
Caption: can eventually eventual consistency be
Caption: feasible
Caption: there's actually a lot of ways around
Caption: this
Caption: but most almost all of them will add
Caption: complexity
Caption: or otherwise impact the user flow for
Caption: example you might just say hey if you
Caption: bought in the past 15 minutes it might
Caption: not show up here
Caption: you might also just choose to show a
Caption: spinner or something
Caption: rather than
Caption: show a stale state to put the customer
Caption: at ease
Caption: either way
Caption: you're adding complexity application
Caption: and
Caption: I did promise we'll get something in
Caption: return
Caption: with strong consistency we get these
Caption: nice consistent views
Caption: it's very easy to use Easy to debug
Caption: easier to reason about easier to write
Caption: it's very nice
Caption: one thing we can do
Caption: with eventually consistent systems is
Caption: really scale out our rights
Caption: with a lot of these strongly consistent
Caption: stores
Caption: it's difficult to scale to descale these
Caption: rights horizontally we can't really have
Caption: a cluster of right nodes that's not how
Caption: it works
Caption: instead
Caption: let's say we have our big SQL Server
Caption: database all we can really do is scale
Caption: it up and up and up
Caption: you're going to hit limits there and
Caption: what you can
Caption: actually provide
Caption: and it's going to be awfully expensive
Caption: with eventually consistent systems
Caption: we're basically accepting hey I don't
Caption: mind if this system returns a stale
Caption: result I'd rather be more available
Caption: this also means
Caption: we get a lot of
Caption: there's a lot of techniques that now
Caption: become available to us to improve right
Caption: throughput
Caption: a lot of those hinge on things like
Caption: asynchronous replication
Caption: making sure that we a
Caption: you know a log of our transactions
Caption: can be sensibly replicated to all of the
Caption: other nodes in our cluster which are
Caption: handling a little slice of our right
Caption: throughput
Caption: so that's consistency we'll actually
Caption: come back a little bit on that when we
Caption: go and talk about
Caption: talk a little bit more about databases
Caption: so how's it actually matter for
Caption: application
Caption: is it okay if a users feed doesn't show
Caption: a message that they've just posted
Caption: potentially
Caption: it's not nice but we know we want to
Caption: handle quite a bit of throughput here
Caption: and for interest sake we're going to say
Caption: yeah we want to make that eventually
Caption: consistent we'll accept a bit of
Caption: complexity to our application
Caption: with follows it's a bit more hazy if you
Caption: follow another user do you necessarily
Caption: expect to see all their messages in your
Caption: feed right away
Caption: I think that's a bit more of a gray area
Caption: You could argue that hey if I'm
Caption: interested in what this person has to
Caption: say I want to get their messages right
Caption: now
Caption: but there could also be a case made that
Caption: we wanted to have that extra performance
Caption: so we don't mind if it takes a little
Caption: while for those friends messages to show
Caption: up
Caption: with viewing our feed
Caption: I'd argue it's much the other way
Caption: we can accept if one of your friends
Caption: posts a new message
Caption: you're not going to see it right away it
Caption: could be five ten seconds it could be a
Caption: minute
Caption: again one of those things you really
Caption: want to drive with product as long as
Caption: the expectations are aligned I think are
Caption: in a good place
Caption: so let's discuss that with our friend
Caption: our interviewer is it okay if the feed
Caption: sometimes out of date sure thing Andrew
Caption: is very nice he just says yes to
Caption: whatever we say
Caption: the last one here a little bit more
Caption: routine
Caption: where's this all this data where is all
Caption: this user data going to go
Caption: if we've got terabytes and terabytes and
Caption: terabytes we need to store it somewhere
Caption: we don't want to go and run out of
Caption: disk spares in our database halfway
Caption: through or run out of some other store
Caption: another one that we're not going to go
Caption: too much into is the durability of your
Caption: data don't always assume you need to
Caption: store all of your data
Caption: there's actually many cases where you're
Caption: going to receive user data and you're
Caption: either going to store it temporarily
Caption: or you're going to store up somewhere
Caption: transient you don't care if that machine
Caption: crashes and that data goes away it's
Caption: it's nice to have
Caption: so similar to what we did for throughput
Caption: let's do a little bit of napkin math
Caption: to see how much data we need to store
Caption: we're going to put up a little bit of a
Caption: simple skimmer here I hope it's not too
Caption: controversial just a unique identifier
Caption: for the message
Caption: when it was created will generate that
Caption: server side
Caption: a message
Caption: and a little bit of metadata around it
Caption: the metadata give us a bit of
Caption: flexibility maybe we want to stuff
Caption: something in there later
Caption: that's not the point the point is we've
Caption: got about 250 bytes of data here
Caption: per row
Caption: we already know we've we've done the
Caption: we've gone asked how many users we have
Caption: how many messages we expect users to
Caption: post each day
Caption: and I hope my math is right here that
Caption: should be 125 gigs a day
Caption: or 40 terabytes a year
Caption: this does matter
Caption: I use postgres Aurora a lot my
Caption: day-to-day
Caption: that has a database name of 128
Caption: terabytes
Caption: that means within a few years we're
Caption: going to start to have to eat this we're
Caption: going to get stuff we're going to have
Caption: to start deleting data
Caption: or we can have a look at an archiving
Caption: process up front
Caption: on the other hand be careful other
Caption: limits as well we just ran to a problem
Caption: where one of our tables is starting to
Caption: exceed it's it's getting really close to
Caption: its limit projects has a limit of 32
Caption: terabytes
Caption: know your technology
Caption: so
Caption: now that we've gone through what are
Caption: abnis has poured both from a functional
Caption: and non-functional sense
Caption: we're going to go with something uh
Caption: a tiny bit more esoteric
Caption: is the schema
Caption: how are we going to send this
Caption: information around our system
Caption: we don't need to talk about it in too
Caption: much detail just enough for us to reason
Caption: about the parts of our system
Caption: remember our three use cases
Caption: want to be able to post a message
Caption: we want to be able to follow other users
Caption: and we want to be able to view
Caption: other uses feeds
Caption: you can see this is missing a whole
Caption: bunch of stuff but we've got the key
Caption: points here you want to post a message
Caption: include your message and I'll follow
Caption: user you include the user ID
Caption: you want to view the feed you're going
Caption: to just send a request and you're
Caption: hopefully going to get back a big list
Caption: of messages
Caption: the last part
Caption: ties it all together but I think it's
Caption: actually the probably the least juicy
Caption: part so if we go back to the very
Caption: standard looking stack we had before
Caption: how are we actually going to talk to
Caption: our services from our client I think we
Caption: what I've seen a lot is people are going
Caption: to generate default to rest
Caption: and that's what I really want to
Caption: hammer down on or push back on
Caption: we don't want to be in the habit of
Caption: defaulting to certain Technologies and
Caption: it's our Instinct because we develop
Caption: expertise with these specific
Caption: Technologies same with our database
Caption: a lot of time a lot of time it's okay
Caption: but I'd like us to be a bit more
Caption: intentional about how we design these
Caption: instead instead of saying we'll just use
Caption: SQL Server because we have that we have
Caption: that there I know how to use it
Caption: a quick overview of some of the other
Caption: things out there that aren't rest I'm
Caption: not going to go too much into rest I
Caption: think most of us are pretty aware of
Caption: how to use a user a lot now day to day
Caption: it's mature
Caption: it's battle tested
Caption: Acacia is really nicely too
Caption: but what about the other stuff
Caption: should we hop straight to graphql
Caption: graphql is really cool right we can do a
Caption: declarative query instead of have it
Caption: being beholden to different endpoints we
Caption: can say hey I just want this data
Caption: I want to get you know these messages
Caption: and
Caption: from these users it's really nice for
Caption: the front-end teams also cuts a bit cuts
Caption: down a bit on how much dead we need to
Caption: fetch with your rest endpoints you
Caption: generally get the whole resource back
Caption: with graph you're only going to get what
Caption: you asked for
Caption: grpc
Caption: it's fancy
Caption: super fast to deserialize and serialize
Caption: data because it's just going to send
Caption: binary representations Over The Wire
Caption: why don't we just use that instead
Caption: well browsers don't have very good
Caption: support for it so if you want to use it
Caption: for
Caption: users to send requests to your server
Caption: you're going to need a proxy in between
Caption: so adding complexity there it is however
Caption: very very nice for server to server
Caption: comes
Caption: there's Traders with that
Caption: but if you have massive scale these
Caption: these are things that are going to save
Caption: you a whole lot of money really going to
Caption: cut down on how much compute you need
Caption: I promise to talk a little about
Caption: databases
Caption: where we're going to put our data
Caption: a lot of the time we're going to default
Caption: to the one of these right
Caption: we're going to default to postgres I
Caption: love postgres I love SQL Server I love
Caption: MySQL
Caption: these have a three things in common that
Caption: run off a relational model a model
Caption: and they're going to generally have one
Caption: writer node and support for read
Caption: replicas and I know there's plugins
Caption: which let you do may let you do more
Caption: replicationally shining around that
Caption: generally
Caption: I think all of these are going to be
Caption: strongly consistent they just have that
Caption: one writer node
Caption: if is in a case where I can't send you
Caption: up-to-date data it's going to fail
Caption: instead the system will become
Caption: unavailable and you're going to get
Caption: nothing
Caption: the benefit of this is of course is much
Caption: easier
Caption: to design your applications you you
Caption: don't have to deal with a lot of that
Caption: eventual consistency
Caption: which you're going to have to deal with
Caption: a lot in
Caption: nosql databases
Caption: a lot of these will
Caption: say they provide strongly consistent
Caption: reads
Caption: but there's going to be a lot of
Caption: asterisks around that
Caption: once we release ourselves from that
Caption: requirement
Caption: to have always up-to-date information
Caption: like I said before a lot of techno a lot
Caption: of techniques become available to you to
Caption: support more availability and more
Caption: throughput even semantically you're
Caption: going to get more availability simply
Caption: because the system will say it's finer
Caption: I'm out of date here's your data
Caption: so that's that big trade-off
Caption: are you willing to accept eventual
Caption: consistency
Caption: if you're going to get a lot of
Caption: throughpoint availability out of it
Caption: there are ways you're going to get more
Caption: complexity in your system and your
Caption: applications
Caption: or you're going to affect the user flow
Caption: in some way
Caption: we also want to talk about
Caption: data flows
Caption: so how
Caption: data flows through our system
Caption: now that we've got our bit of our schema
Caption: we can have a think about okay these
Caption: requests are coming in
Caption: can we do some pre-computation so that
Caption: when the user goes to fetch a certain
Caption: piece of data it's already there hot in
Caption: the case or in a service somewhere
Caption: as a little bit of Flip Side you have
Caption: caching
Caption: once you've done a bit of work to
Caption: compute something maybe someone's feed
Caption: or something like that
Caption: why not just save it somewhere so if
Caption: they ask again for it we can bring it
Caption: back quickly we don't have to do all
Caption: that work of looking up
Caption: who you know who are their friends
Caption: what messages have their friends sent to
Caption: build up that picture every time it's a
Caption: lot of work
Caption: there's concerns around this as well
Caption: your caching layer can fail
Caption: you don't want your application to come
Caption: unavailable so there's there's
Caption: complexity here again
Caption: for performance
Caption: it's common theme right
Caption: so I'm actually going to give you
Caption: something that's not particularly it's
Caption: not a perfect architecture or even a
Caption: great architecture
Caption: but it's something that I can back up is
Caption: something where if you ask me questions
Caption: about it I can at least give you some
Caption: amount of explanation about why I've
Caption: done things a certain way
Caption: I've cut out the static assets part
Caption: that's a bit less interesting
Caption: we've got our three main requests
Caption: posting a message
Caption: following another user
Caption: and getting a feedback of what our
Caption: friends have said
Caption: so
Caption: going back to talking about
Caption: picking the right technology
Caption: and I'll add some caveats into this
Caption: later
Caption: we've put in a graph DB for our so uh
Caption: for our social graph service
Caption: we've got something optimized to help us
Caption: get a list of friends faster and user
Caption: graph databases are pretty cool they
Caption: store relationships as a first class
Caption: thing not the element themselves
Caption: that means when you're looking for
Caption: relationships based off a certain node
Caption: it's going to be much faster than doing
Caption: the same on a relational database
Caption: [Music]
Caption: and a lot a lot of these are eventually
Caption: consistent
Caption: but as we said before we're going to go
Caption: accept that we've discussed that with
Caption: product it's it's okay you're not going
Caption: to get your friend's latest messages
Caption: right away
Caption: similar when we post a message so we can
Caption: do a bit of pre-computation here we
Caption: don't want to lose these messages that
Caption: would be bad if everyone just you know
Caption: you post all these messages and you want
Caption: to see them later reminisce about what
Caption: you and your friends have been talking
Caption: about so we'll
Caption: put a database up there somewhere
Caption: could be postgres could be
Caption: they both work
Caption: but we're also going to send something
Caption: to an asynchronous worker a feed updater
Caption: so when we know that a message has come
Caption: in we're going to go up and update
Caption: your people who are following you we're
Caption: going to inject this new message into
Caption: all of those feeds
Caption: that means
Caption: if we've done a good job keeping our
Caption: caching layer consistent when requests
Caption: come in
Caption: a lot of users especially for the active
Caption: users you're going to get your feed
Caption: right away our service hat can do a
Caption: whole lot less work in
Caption: generating users feeds
Caption: so
Caption: it's in considering things like that
Caption: I think we get a lot of value
Caption: you can explain your decisions
Caption: you're explaining why using something
Caption: and not something else
Caption: you're picking the right technology
Caption: there's next steps there's things I
Caption: haven't covered
Caption: so
Caption: moving forwards doing a bit better than
Caption: this
Caption: you want to find ways where you can deal
Caption: with less data
Caption: and that's where we kind of talked about
Caption: can we pre-compute something
Caption: can we case something just so we have
Caption: less
Caption: data that needs to be computed on the
Caption: Fly Center here and there
Caption: picking the right tool
Caption: so really reasoning about what
Caption: I'm using this technology because this
Caption: I know it's got these cons but that's
Caption: okay
Caption: and we're all in love with product about
Caption: that
Caption: I've also haven't talked about some of
Caption: the more
Caption: um
Caption: for example sharding it's going to
Caption: improve your right throughput but
Caption: that's kind of a whole Topic in itself
Caption: there's more complexity there how are
Caption: you going to split your data up among
Caption: different shards things like that
Caption: few edge cases as well
Caption: like
Caption: sorry
Caption: while our solution works well for
Caption: cases where users don't have a lot of
Caption: followers
Caption: because that little async worker is
Caption: going to go and update people's feeds
Caption: if we have Lady Gaga come in with a 30
Caption: million followers and post a message
Caption: that's going to be massive ride volume
Caption: these are the kind of edge cases that
Caption: you want to think about
Caption: there's a cautionary tale here as well
Caption: you don't want to be when you're picking
Caption: the right tool
Caption: you also want to think about your team's
Caption: skill set
Caption: there's
Caption: not much reason to adapt a technology
Caption: there's a few ways you can approach it
Caption: either
Caption: you
Caption: tend to shy away from using a technology
Caption: that your team doesn't know how to use
Caption: or that you think you're going to have
Caption: difficulty hiring for
Caption: another way and this takes a lot of
Caption: effort is to drive consensus
Caption: among your wider engineering team about
Caption: adopting a technology because it allows
Caption: us to do XYZ and I can't stress how much
Caption: effort and how exhausting that can be
Caption: even in the best run organizations
Caption: you'll want to look at procurement as
Caption: well there's going to be a lot of people
Caption: in the company who are going to be
Caption: pretty unhappy if you're like I want to
Caption: grab this technology uh
Caption: going to grab you know cockroach here
Caption: and I like this from AWS and I like this
Caption: from Azure and I like this from gcp
Caption: it's going to be a real headache there's
Caption: contracts here that need to be
Caption: negotiated there's money
Caption: it's a lot work more work than it might
Caption: appear at first thought
Caption: and there's always you aren't going to
Caption: need it
Caption: I think we have a natural tendency to
Caption: want to avoid
Caption: maybe future uncertainty or future risk
Caption: so
Caption: we can end up over engineering our
Caption: systems
Caption: we'll put this big eventually consistent
Caption: system in place
Caption: and spend a lot more time
Caption: working around the complexities of that
Caption: then building out our core system
Caption: so please please please there's a lot of
Caption: you aren't going to need it
Caption: you can apply here
Caption: remember what your competitive
Caption: advantages and focus on that
Caption: there generally is time to
Caption: scale up later to a bit of
Caption: re-architecturing if you're doing well
Caption: so with this we're doing a bit better
Caption: we've maybe adopted grpc for our service
Caption: to service comms
Caption: we know what sort of throughput we need
Caption: to handle and we have a plan in place
Caption: for it
Caption: and product isn't getting any nasty
Caption: surprises we've reasoned about
Caption: how
Caption: our system is going to perform it's how
Caption: it's going to behave for customers
Caption: it's always going to be buggy I don't
Caption: think we can solve that one that's a
Caption: tell for a different day
Caption: the point is we're not trying to
Caption: completely avoid failure here we're just
Caption: trying to make sure we do our due
Caption: diligence and we've reasoned about our
Caption: system sensibly
Caption: so
Caption: the key takeaway is just quickly please
Caption: please please talk to products ask lots
Caption: of questions we need to stop this habit
Caption: I still see of waiting for product to
Caption: give us our requirements or product just
Caption: giving the engineering team requirements
Caption: and not really expecting any questions
Caption: we can get a lot of value out of just
Caption: talking
Caption: again designed with intent explain why
Caption: you've chosen something
Caption: and why you haven't chosen something
Caption: design often
Caption: you're going to do this a lot at your
Caption: workplace if you get into this good
Caption: habit you're going to get a lot of very
Caption: you're going to build a lot of
Caption: experience assistant design is something
Caption: that does take a lot of experience but
Caption: if you get in the habit of thinking
Caption: about it the right way
Caption: it's really going to improve your
Caption: ability to
Caption: reason
Caption: design makes sense right practice
Caption: on the side there's so much great
Caption: information about their white papers
Caption: Tech blogs videos go and do your study
Caption: look at how Twitter's built there's lots
Caption: of stuff out there Instagram Netflix
Caption: there's so much free material out there
Caption: you can kind of run through why they did
Caption: a certain way and then take a step back
Caption: and try to design it yourself
Caption: cool uh thank you very much
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: Nick that was a great talk so to get a
Caption: job at Google I don't follow the recipe
Caption: I just follow that recipe and innovate
Caption: yes
Caption: um
Caption: at the interview itself you just want to
Caption: follow in a structured way and this was
Caption: actually something that
Caption: we
Caption: really agreed was a really nice
Caption: structured way of doing it
Caption: non-functional requirements function
Caption: requirements like how much how much
Caption: traffic your servers are going to need
Caption: to handle schema stuff like that you
Caption: just want to be able to explain these
Caption: things and it's so important when you're
Caption: talking to stakeholders or senior
Caption: engineering leadership as well so I can
Caption: use that throughout my working life
Caption: really absolutely perfect okay so I'm
Caption: going to open up the floor for a q a
Caption: session uh does anyone have a question
Caption: for Nick
Caption: okay this man over here please
Caption: hey
Caption: working yeah
Caption: uh well thanks for excellent talk
Caption: um so you you mentioned you know uh
Caption: always reason about why you choose one
Caption: tag over the other and it's built on
Caption: assumption that you know all the tech
Caption: and you pretty much and you know you
Caption: know what's out there you know
Caption: Alternatives you know pros and cons
Caption: what's like the the best behavior if you
Caption: deal with some systems that you don't
Caption: know much about like I don't know
Caption: someone told you to design time series
Caption: heavy application and you don't have a
Caption: previous experience so how would you
Caption: you know operate in these kind of
Caption: situations yeah that's a really good
Caption: question if someone approached me and
Caption: said hey I'd like to build this with a
Caption: Time series database
Caption: I'd basically say why the first thing
Caption: you want to ask is what are we trying to
Caption: solve
Caption: what are we
Caption: what is the problem that needs a Time
Caption: series database for example if it's
Caption: something like
Caption: obviously time based right like a lot of
Caption: observability metrics something like
Caption: that
Caption: then
Caption: sure
Caption: it's not something I'd probably
Caption: discourage people from trying to Deep
Caption: dive into everything that's not
Caption: something you can do
Caption: instead you want to have awareness of
Caption: the different classes of database so
Caption: you've got your like you know why column
Caption: stores like Cassandra or your time
Caption: series database like you mentioned graph
Caption: database and so on
Caption: as long as you have an awareness of it
Caption: then you could you can go back and say
Caption: Hey Okay after our discussion looks like
Caption: the time series database is the right
Caption: way to go I don't have much experience
Caption: on this I'm going to have to do a bit of
Caption: a deep dive on it and I think that's
Caption: that's a plenty reasonable path forwards
Caption: does that kind of ask the question yeah
Caption: I think there's a
Caption: Indian views so what can happen is if
Caption: you thrive technology you aren't very
Caption: confident about it can really fall apart
Caption: and that's why stress is so important to
Caption: learn about the underlying concepts of
Caption: how these things work instead rather
Caption: than saying I need to know I need
Caption: to know SQL
Caption: you want to learn about how these how
Caption: SQL databases operate right so at the
Caption: lowest level they've got these logs that
Caption: they need to make durable and from that
Caption: they'll kind of project some data out of
Caption: it
Caption: with eventually consistent systems
Caption: you've got
Caption: distributed rights
Caption: and then there's some work there around
Caption: gaining consensus around what what data
Caption: is there that kind of stuff so my best
Caption: advice is to really focus on the
Caption: concepts that power these Technologies
Caption: don't focus on Technologies themselves
Caption: too much if you do this well you can
Caption: actually look at what benefits a new
Caption: product proposes and say I reckon they
Caption: did it this way
Caption: and if you're getting that right often
Caption: and if you if you're able to say I
Caption: reckon cockroach does things this way
Caption: that's how they got these Secret Sauce
Caption: but I reckon it's something like this if
Caption: you can start looking at that level
Caption: you're really on the right track I think
Caption: thank you
Caption: yes t
Caption: you mentioned about a tip if you have
Caption: how you go about startup that discussion
Caption: with products how do you actually drive
Caption: that I think that was a great takeaway
Caption: for me yeah thank you yeah
Caption: um so that's a good question
Caption: it's it depends on your organization a
Caption: lot if it's a very hierarchical one and
Caption: you're just getting tickets over the
Caption: fence it's a lot of work to go and reach
Caption: that Gap but I think
Caption: generally
Caption: you just acting good faith for example
Caption: if you go
Caption: to a product person to someone who's a
Caption: real decision maker and you say hey
Caption: here's what I've been asked to build
Caption: I'd like to know what the problems are
Caption: trying to solve are and really get some
Caption: consensus on what we're trying to
Caption: deliver
Caption: I think most people will be very open to
Caption: that I think a lot of
Caption: non-engineering people would take to
Caption: that really kindly
Caption: I hope that I hope that answers your
Caption: question
Caption: and
Caption: okay
Caption: uh the last question anymore
Caption: okay well I've got some good news uh
Caption: morning tea is uh served in the foyer
Caption: but a big thank you to Nick
Caption: thanks everyone